sometimes it is hard to know disliked
imitate art or this part imitate life
but recently james corden world
philosopher weighed in mostly he's known
for carpool karaoke and shaming fat
chambers while you're encouraging people
to think about what goes into their
mouths just think a little harder about
what comes out of yours
but recently he predicted and I'm not
joking about that I know him being a
little tongue in cheek here but actually
predicted a huge Silicon Valley disaster
to a tee when he mocked fairness in a
sketch okay so you guys all know who
Theron OSIS right one of the most famous
examples of Silicon Valley overhyping a
startup it gets overvalued and the
technology is not really there this lady
named Elizabeth Holmes the founder of
Barrow knows who famously faked her
voice to be lower and she talked like
this I believe the individual is the
answer
well her company was valued for billions
of dollars after she proclaimed to the
world that she could do blood testing on
a small scale so you could bring
medicine to everyone you wouldn't have
to draw up vials of blood every time
someone needed a basic blood test thanks
to this like micro testing technology
she was working on supposed to
revolutionize health and you know they
got tons and tons and tons of funding
except the technology was bogus it
didn't work this famous meltdown and
overall she's just been built into this
like villains sociopath archetype of
Silicon Valley and here is where James
Corden is a great James Corden comes in
because he wrote a sketch in March 2019
it was basically mocking what would the
next ridiculous health craze be and
accidentally predicted the future my
dream
is to transform the landscape of modern
medicine as we know it everyone
worshiped the ground he walked on we
were all convinced he was going to be
the next Steve Jobs this madness on the
village is building a multi-billion
dollar health company so pretty obvious
sketch you know obviously mocking
Elizabeth Holmes the way she talks but
then James explains what the big idea is
I had a very simple but powerful vision
what if every person in America had a
box in their house and every person
could poo in that box you leave it there
and we'll do the rest
what if no no not what if this thing
already exists and it's called you biome
little did he know they were already
selling the exact identity talking about
they would send people packages that
people would put their poop samples into
and then you would send them a way to
get tested for help everybody I'm
pooping live in my bathroom here with a
kid before you ask it's like they these
clips literally find me and this is why
for all its problems is why I adore
YouTube you can on the one hand find
mainstream media on this platform but on
the other hand just a click away
is a guy enthusiastically doing a swab
tutorial on camera a poop sample it says
after a bowel movement white normally
run the swab over the used toilet paper
just enough to lightly color the entire
swab but yes this is totally real this
guy's not kidding this is the premise of
you biome and much like Thera knows the
idea was who's gonna revolutionize
medicine by allowing your average person
to genetically sequence their poo
instead of their blood and thereby
improve their health
but just like Thera knows the technology
simply wasn't there yet and this is
where Jessica Richmond just like
Elizabeth Holmes before her made some
critical errors
she didn't fake her voice but she did
fake her age to appear younger so she
could appear on one of those like Forbes
40 under 40 type lists there's also the
small matter of you know the insurance
fraud that the FBI investigated them for
but let's go back to James Corden can
you imagine being in a writers room with
one of these late night shows and trying
to think what's the best way to satirize
Silicon Valley's willingness to swallow
literally anything as long as it's
shrouded in the appearance of
cutting-edge science and you come up
with the perfect idea right obviously
poop nobodies this this is not real life
now obviously no one's gonna be
investing in a poop elf this boss is the
you do that in March 2019 only to find
out that in September of 2019 the
company you invent you thought you
invented in your imagination just
declared bankruptcy after taking
hundreds of millions of dollars of
venture capital funding this thing
existed you biome was valued at hundreds
of millions of dollars for pute health
which is why I always say this you know
you shouldn't feel bad if you get
scammed because you know if you're out
there you've just been fallen prey to a
guru ad or any of these clowns you know
you may have only spent $2,000 investors
spent hundreds of millions of dollars on
this company only to find out that it
was a bunch of crap literally literally
but I guess the most shocking thing to
me about you biome is that so few people
that I know of have heard of this I only
heard of it just a few days ago you know
when Theron hos happened it was all over
the news but with you biome only a few
outlets covered it mostly they're
founded just kind of stepped down they
declared bankruptcy and they sold off
all their assets even as reports of
their shoddy science were coming out
even as reports of them using tactics of
and this is their own words here from
one of their bankruptcy documents
questionable legality even as reports
were coming out that they were using
advertising that included stock photos
instead of real photos that pretended to
be real customers
you know this classic guru stuff right
and yet it's all been kind of wiped away
a poop company that allegedly commits
insurance fraud it fakes testimonials
the founders lying about her age an
ex-employee comes out saying that taking
one of these tests is like going to a
really expensive homeopathic doctor and
yet hardly anyone reports on it well
hardly anybody but the hardest-hitting
journalist I know about things just
snowballed into this crazy situation
people started sending their boxes back
demanding answers
it just kept piling up that's a lot of
poop that's a lot of food yeah
boxes of poo what was coming out of his
mouth wasn't even reality it was Loomis
gig as CEO of your bio mr. vo is I get
to make a lot of poop jokes what dream
sometimes parody just meets reality and
it's just insane to watch I hope if this
videos done anything it's show you guys
that even the smartest people can be
taken in by a clever sounding pitch and
fear of missing out so next time you
guys hear about some insane startup
that's gonna revolutionize health maybe
think twice because we've fallen for
this not once now but at least twice by
my count probably more than that and
it's time to maybe second-guess these
people when they come to us telling us
that there are poop is gonna solve all
our problems so with that said let me
know what you guys think in the comments
below and I'll see you guys in the next
one and as always don't forget to smash
like and subscribe
thank you
[Music]
you want my feces